foreign
David renew 2030 is a coalition of
regional climate foundations think tanks
and ngos working around the world to
scale wind and solar
why is this so important in the fight to
protect our climate well because the
power sector is responsible for 50 of
all the emissions we need to reduce
before 2030. it needs to go first
because we need it to Electrify other
sectors
we also need to make sure that the
transition is fast as well as first it
needs to go fast we've got a window of
just seven years seven years to see
those exponential curves hit the roof
and it also needs to be fair
we need to make sure that the community
is involved a consulted deeply on the
sighting of those renewable energy
installations we need to make sure that
the supply chains and the transition
minerals are equitably sourced and we
also need to make sure that precious
Finance flows to where it's needed most
so this is what renew 2030 does
powered by philanthropy it takes the
funds to the groups that need it most in
the geographies where the transition
needs the most in order to impact the
power sector so what are the obstacles
then you'd think with the phenomenal
cost reductions we've seen in renewable
energy that this would just be a runaway
success story
but that's not the case there are all
sorts of non-cost barriers that
communities and societies need to work
on barriers such of lack of ambition
policy barriers such as lack of
investment barriers such as flow
permitting and planning not just for
wind and solar themselves
but also for the grids that we need to
balance them reliably and securely
barriers like misinformation in the
information Wars we've been talking
about there are really serious problems
about misinformation and of course
skills for workers in a just transition
so David
renew 2030 what it does is it supports
groups and it does so with a set of
levers levers that are tried and tested
to help us work on the transition policy
and advocacy to name just a few
narrative building and storytelling
and we do that across the globe in their
geographies that have the highest
emissions and we support groups working
on those barriers I want to tell you a
little bit more about some of those
groups Sergio chavier works in the
northeast of Brazil and they're working
to advocate for sustainable energy parks
he works in Senegal helping agricultural
workers to access energy
he works in South Korea and he works on
policy and finance and one of my
personal favorite partners that we
support is Janet jetubu she helps female
leaders and Engineers to enter careers
in the global wind industry so that's
what renew 2030 does it helps bring the
power of philanthropy to the groups that
matter the most that's amazing but that
also makes it sounds like communities
are maybe as important as National
governments in this
that's right David I mean for many years
we've focused on National governments
and they are critical don't get me wrong
they're really really important
but communities have incredible power to
shape the power system of the future
that we want to see they can engage in
community-owned energy they can engage
in local policy they can engage in the
workforce as part of a just transition
so communities are Central to the thesis
of renew 2030. okay so sounds great but
what makes you think that this
collaborative approach will work I mean
you've got lots of progress but we need
exponential change as you said we do
need exponential change David this is
what worries me so we have to
collaborate between businesses
governments and civil society and we've
seen in countries like Uruguay Denmark
Kenya many others the exponential growth
is possible so what renew 2030 does is
it works with a group of regional
climate Foundation leaders to bring the
funding to the groups of on the ground
with the data they need the toolkit of
strategies and also the ability to
convene together and talk and listen and
renew 2030 is therefore the thing that
gives me great hope that we can see
exponential growth in the places that we
need I love the sound of that so when
you succeed what does the world of 2030
look like
we actually need these groups to create
disruptive change
times five the installation of wind and
solar that we have now by 2030.
done in a just and Equitable way so my
hope is by 2030 the work that we do will
have helped put us on a footing for a
climate secure safe future it's 50 of
all the emissions we need to get at
remember so this is very serious
and my hope is that at the same time we
will actually have created local jobs
and clean air
and most importantly for me personally
is that we will have helped to give
communities the opportunity to shape
affordable clean electricity for their
homes and their schools and their
businesses thank you thank you
[Applause]